from movies to TV this year has already
delivered a ton of creepy creatures that
obviously came from the most deviously
creative minds in the biz and after
seeing these menacing things come to
life on screen it's probably a safe bet
that most of us will be losing in an
unusual amount of sleep this year as
well here are a few of the scariest new
monsters at 2017 Winslow on The Walking
Dead The Walking Dead 7 season presented
Jadis and her community a group of
people who've relied on garbage to
create giant walls to keep themselves
safe that in and of itself was weird
enough but then their pet zombie Winslow
came into the picture that's a special
moment for small screen scare history
Rick who wanted to gain the favor of
Jada's his crew for his impending battle
with negan was thrown into a pit with a
spiked undead beast and had to find a
way to penetrate his dangerous helmet to
save his own skin trouble was he was
decked out with knives and a helmet
reinforced with metal from a gas tank so
not only did we find out just how much
Jadis doesn't play around when it comes
to protecting her junkyard life but we
also got to see just how much of a
resourceful survivor Rick Grimes really
is with his back against the wall or you
know the garbage
any wise from it kids of the 80s and 90s
who watched the first iteration of
Stephen King's it will no doubt recall
the eerie sickening feeling that washed
over them whenever Tim Curry's Pennywise
the clown arrives at torture the
children of Derry and it looks like this
year's revival effort will be just as
terrifying if the first glimpses of the
sinister cinematic clown or any
indication unlike Curry's version there
appears to be less surface humor present
in the new Pennywise played by bill
skarsgård what's really going to earn
prime placement in people's nightmares
with this one though is how grimy does
Pennywise seems to be compared to the
last one plus there's the return of the
red balloon that image alone is enough
to induce a shudder from an entire
generation of horror fans Kong Skull
Island lizard monster three tongues
countless teeth and a grunt scream that
sounds like a velociraptor that's a
recipe for absolute disaster Kong school
islands resident skull crawlers gave new
meaning to the concept of an ancient
apex predator as only one mega gorilla
could survive their systematic slaughter
of his species King Kong it's basically
the equivalent of what would happen if
the Cloverfield monster mated with that
real-life Dino size croc that's been
haunting South Carolina golfers this
year garden of the galaxy volume 2's
octo beast thanks to movies like Pirates
of the Caribbean Dead Man's Chest and
clashes a Titans we've certainly
encountered our fair share of cracking
like beets
and movies past but what guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 pulled off is something
particularly awful the gang goes toe to
toe with this toothy space octopus
monstrosity and Drax does it with just a
pair of daggers that's a fight fit for a
destroyer right as he leaps in to take
on the tentacle creature yet another
layer of gums opens up to receive him
and it's just a whole nother level of
nope
Calvin from life when are our fictional
friends going to just learn that you
can't go playing with alien life-forms
and expect things to go well for anyone
involved like a lot of outerspace
thrillers when these International Space
Station astronauts actually discover
Martian life things are not what they
seem what begins as a cute little
shimmying blob turns into a full-on
intergalactic nightmare for everyone on
board with the creature named Calvin who
can think feed on almost anything and
wants to instinctively destroy for the
sink of its own growth unlike a lot of
on-screen aliens there's nothing
ridiculous or anthropomorphic about this
thing it's just plain horrible and a
a believable way I'm Annette from the
mummy for those who remain skeptical
about the Tom Cruise LED reboot of the
mummy franchise we've got two words for
you sofia boutella the up-and-coming
actress portrays an ancient Egyptian
princess named Alma net who was entombed
2,000 years ago after murdering her king
father then is accidentally resurrected
into a power-hungry world wanderer who
has no bones about being an evil Empress
of darkness not only that she had the
power to revive humans to do her deadly
bidding but she's also pretty terrible
to look at so you got some spooky I
salute maneuver that's just bound to
strike a nerve with anybody who uses
their own single iris eyes to see it
alien covenant Xenomorphs with alien
covenant Ridley Scott is returning to
form with his aliens that have tormented
audiences for decades the footage from
this movie harkens back to imagery we've
seen of these species before but there's
also some menacing new material at play
- and here we thought the chest burster
from the original film was peak
petrification but this looks pretty good
- holy man talk about a bug on the
windshield thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to